welcome to Moab Utah surrounded by
thousands of square miles of Mars like
Red Rock landscape and the mighty
Colorado River surprisingly Utah has
yielded fossils from more dinosaur
species than any other state and that
fact alone makes for a thrilling story
150 million years in the making it
involves the Civil War an incredible
cargo Airlift mission and the site of a
dig that could unearth a major discovery
a missing piece in the dinosaur family
tree let's take a deeper look at had a
fossil and the long-lost see our light
in the early 1800s there was this patch
of desert in eastern Utah that got some
attention for being an easy natural
crossing point on the Colorado River
along the old Spanish Trail good for
trades a few key railroad lines later it
was 1859 and a u.s. geological
expedition discovered this giant awesome
fossil in the area but before they could
unearth it civil war broke out yep and
the fossil was long forgotten for almost
150 years in 2014 National Geographic
Explorer John foster picked up with a
civil war and a few other scientists in
the 80s and 90s left off and his
excavation team began to find the
remnants of a sauropod huh well you've
probably heard of the brontosaurus or
the Brachiosaurus their sauropods long
necks long tails four-legged eats leaves
turns out they have a common ancestor
and at least in North America it might
be this guy distro feeis but wait why
are there dinosaurs here where does this
leave eating dinosaur get his greens in
the desert
well this arid desert was actually a
long lost seat 160 million years ago
this place was an oasis think Spring
Break same bars drinks with little
umbrellas but like like the dinosaur
version not a bad place for the
potentially oldest sauropod in North
America to call home
relocating these dinosaur vertebra for
research is no joke
each piece weighs a whopping 800 pounds
and has to be covered in plaster and the
team is on the edge of a cliff it sounds
like a job for the dinosaur fossil
airlift cargo helicopter service okay
that's that's actually not really a
thing but watch this pretty unbelievable
but Foster and his team began unearthing
in this long-lost see could be a missing
link in North America's dinosaur family
tree
welcome to the family distro feeis but
that's not the whole story for more
watch new episodes of Explorer on
National Geographic
[Music]